how's it going Brad nice welcome to more
oculus we're gonna play the SS a slim ya
gonna do the a slim but that's safe
after that I'm done all right we got a
deal all right great
only cuz I love me some ass the a slim
I love I love blimps especially as oh
god it's so [ __ ] loud I played so
much louder than a breath so don't even
come talk to me unless you're cool and
stuff
of course you're cool now I feel that
you're the coolest you're watching me so
obviously you're cool all right this is
not as creepy as the last one I don't
know why what do we got here
secure the gate a warning oh god never
mind we're [ __ ]
don't you just hate when GU snips are
growing on your face my best no jump
line or jävla Fichte bleep laughs Rita
okay we're going inside that yes great
idea oh [ __ ]
we are so good are those people
screaming and all it's probably just
pipes going together and stuffs oh [ __ ]
hello Oh God we can look inside them I
don't want to I all got a got a pleasure
okay all right all right we just have to
live through this hello
stop being a little [ __ ] like I am
because I will not get you anywhere in
life unless you want to be a [ __ ]
I don't know hello a blood everywhere
friend [ __ ] tastic all right that's
what a lovely poster you know what at
least they had posters this place may
have what that what what was that oh no
I can't handle people what is that a
hand
what the hell hand get out of here hand
what is that teeth oh god what the [ __ ]
are you you're an octopus
you should be happy something a [ __ ]
all right don't
to me I don't talk dr. Pisces it's a
rule I am well less they're famous of
course but you don't see a lot of famous
act what are you doing here Oh Oh my
[ __ ] I did it
tit all right it was only a gas lag
we're fine
we've survived gas lakhs before you
don't you dare come alive you ugly bed
this is like this is exactly like a
real-life haunted mansion thing you know
when you walk through it feels identical
don't you dare attack me I'm nice I'm
[ __ ] nice a [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
Oh God Oh God [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you
Oh jab la vista why hello alright you
know what [ __ ] them the sooner we can
get through this the better
all right what is this oh they're locked
then oh god it's like torture Champa nee
nee nee nee nee oh oh okay okay okay all
right
he can't hurt us he can't hurt us it's
just a game you're a man a woman at it
okay um oh god I don't want to go there
what do i do what do i do whatever do
whatever do oh oh what do I do
I don't want to go in there it's so dark
let's take it easy easy easy easy
hello oh God
uh-huh whatwhat was that what was that
what did you do don't touch me oh it's
so weird what the [ __ ] what am I doing
here
something definitely happened something
got unlocked this got unlock didn't it
he's [ __ ] with me and I don't like it
I'm not oh god you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I will shutdown you if I could I would
literally [ __ ] on him I swear to God if
it was real life he would have my poo
pourri in his face and it would taste
like butter okay all right we're good
[ __ ] oh god oh god what the it must be
the Octopussy hello mister Octopussy
all right I guess we this is such a good
oculus rift game we're jävla I don't
feel it's single bit of motion sickness
this not held back there and see him
that's [ __ ] up Oh God
okay ready there damn what does it say
this is not your last chance to turn
[ __ ] you
I'm Swedish you don't tell us what to do
and if you have to tell us what to do
you don't write it on blood in that
ladder it's extremely offensive on a
wall I mean oh god he's [ __ ] where is he
how did he do that now how the hell did
he do that I don't want to know actually
don't show me all right I'm just trying
to be careful as it is and sneak up on
me what is this oh not down more oh god
I feel like he's behind me I'm just
running I don't want to look what is
this what is that oh okay okay okay
all right it's just dead people [ __ ]
them they can't hurt me unless they're
dead wait what okay more down I was
hoping for that please more down I said
a minute ago tonight I said that didn't
I yeah I said it I need to focus on
something else seriously all right
bouncy boobs bouncy boobs hello sir
are you crying about Jesus bouncy boobs
I got that itch though all right let's
get this bouncy boobs off my chest oh
that looks fun I'm gonna go
I'm busy got an important ended bouncing
boobs the [ __ ] is happening what is
going on
Oh God not having me so mean
okay look at that oh my god this is so
bad this is so bad
got Nate okay oh god oh god
no no no no no hello what is that oh god
what I mean the wheel ship what what
this who's writing the wheelchair what
what is going up no oh god no please
just walk Oh guys oh [ __ ] oh no it's
happening
oh no oh god oh god gross be with me
please
just hold me
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
what the [ __ ]
what is that
be nice to handicaps be nice to
handicaps